Hi, I'm Michael, co-founder and CTO of
14.ai, where we're building an AI native
customer support
platform. Our systems interact directly
with end users, rely on LLMs in
production, and have to operate reliably
under uncertain conditions. To manage
that complexity, we use effect, a
TypeScript library designed for building
robust, type- safe, and composable
systems. The TypeScript language itself
gives us a great foundation, but it
starts to fall short when we're dealing
with unreliable APIs, complex
dependencies between systems,
non-deterministic model outputs, or
longunning workflows. Effect gives us
the tools to handle such situations
confidently as our platform evolves.
Among other things, it provides strong
type guarantees across the stack,
powerful composition primitives,
built-in concurrency streaming
interruptions and retry mechanisms,
structured error modeling, and a clean
dependency injection system that makes
testing and modernization much easier.
It also offers very easy observability
via open telemetry.
In addition to helping us build more
stable, testable, and maintainable code
at scale, we chose effect also because
it can be gradually adopted in an
existing codebase and feels like a
natural extension of TypeScript
itself. So quickly about our
architecture, we use effect across our
entire stack. Here are how the main
components fit together. We have a React
front end that powers everything from
dashboards to the agents ID, a knowledge
management, insights, analytics, and
SDKs. Then we have an internal RPC
server that handles app logic built on
effect RPC and a modified version of
tanstack query on the front end. Our
public API server uses effect HTTP with
an open API docs autogenerated from
annotated schemas. Our data processing
engine syncs data from CRM, docs, and
databases and process it for real-time
analytics and reporting. Agent workflows
are written in a custom DSL built on
effect, allowing us to mix deterministic
and nondeterministic behavior. And
finally, we use a postgress database for
both data and vector storage with
effects SQL handling
queries. Everything is modeled using
effect schemas. So we get runtime
validation, encoding, decoding, type
safe input and output handling across
the stack and even autogenerated
documentation for free. Our agents are
basically planners. They take input from
the user, come up with a plan, choose
the right action, workflow or sub agent,
executes them and repeats until the task
is complete.
Actions are small focused units of
execution like fetching payment info or
searching through logs. You can think of
them like tool calls. Workflows are
deterministic multi-step processes. For
instance, cancelling a subscription
might involve collecting a reason,
offering a retention option if
applicable, checking eligibility, and
then performing the cancellation.
Finally, sub agents group together
related actions and workflows into
larger domain specific modules like a
building agent or a log retrieval
agent. In order to model this
complexity, we built a domain specific
language from workflows using effects
functional pipe based system as the
foundation. And this lets us express
things like branching, sequencing,
retries, state transitions, and memory
in a very clear and composable way. Now,
as you're powering mission critical
systems, reliability really is key. If
one LM provider fails, for instance, we
fall back to another provider with
similar performance characteristics. For
instance, GPT4 mini could fall back to
GD flash 2.0 for tool calling. We model
this with retry policies which also
track state. So, we avoid retrying fail
providers. Often times, answers are
streamed to the end user. We for that
purpose duplicate token streams. One
directly to the user and one for storage
on our side. For instance, analytics
effect allows us to do that very
easily. For testing, we make heavy use
of dependency injection to mock LM
providers and simulate failure
scenarios. With this DI approach, we can
easily swap services providers with mock
versions without actually affecting the
internals of our
system. This brings us to developer
experience. With all these tools
available, the developer experience for
building agentic systems in effect
really is excellent. First of all, it's
schema centric. So we define input,
output, and error types up front. And
those schemas come with powerful
encoding and decoding built in. They
provide strong type safety guarantees
and they're automatically documented so
we can get clarity and consistency
without extra effort. Dependency
injection obviously is also a strong
point. So services are provided at the
entry point of our systems. that can be
composed however we need and easily
marked for testing. Dependencies are
present at the type level guaranteed at
compile time that all required services
are provided. Services themselves are
modular and composable which makes it
easy to override behavior or swap in
different implementations without
affecting the internals of our system.
And finally, effect provides very strong
guard rails. Engineers who are new to
Typescript can become productive quickly
because the framework helps prevent
common mistakes. Once you get past the
initial learning curve, it's harder to
fall into bad
patterns. A bit about the lessons
learned here. So, effect is powerful,
but using it well takes discipline. It's
really nice to write code for the happy
path. Things look really clean and
explicit, and everything seems to just
flow. But that can also give you a false
sense of safety. It's easy to
accidentally catch errors somewhere
upstream or out of sight and silently
lose important failures if you're not
careful. Dependency injection is another
area I would say where it can be hard
sometimes to grasp at scale. It's great
in principle but tracing where services
are provided especially when you're
dealing with multiple layers or
subsystems can become kind of hard to
follow. The learning curve is real.
effect is a big ecosystem with a lot of
concepts and tools. It can be
overwhelming at first, but really once
you get past this initial bump, things
just somehow start to click and from
that point on, the benefits compound.
So, at the end of the day, effect helps
us build systems that are predictable
and resilient, but it's not magic. You
still have to
think. One of the great things about
effect is that you don't have to go all
in on day one. You can adopt it
incrementally. Start with a single
service or endpoint and build from
there. Effect is especially useful for
LLM and AI based systems where
reliability and coping with
non-determinism really matter. You want
your systems to be predictable and
observable and effect gives you the
right tools to make it
happen. It also brings the rigor of
functional programming into real world
TypeScript but in a way that's practical
for production use. You don't have to be
a functional programming purist to get a
lot of value. Just start small and let
the benefits build up over
time. So if you're building with agents,
LLMs or exploring effect, feel free to
get in touch. Thank you.